what is the relationship between film
festivals and distributors have you met
any distributors at a film festival that
you've shown on the horizon it not yes
but again it's I think when you don't
have a big-name actor in your film
you're gonna have shitty deals yeah I
think it's just it's I think even you
guys you had videos before talk about it
and when you have so I think that that's
where my fame I'm releasing it on iTunes
Google Amazon Vimeo or for video on
demand I think that's the best way to
reach out a lot of people and if you
don't have big names then distribution
is not gonna knock at the door I had
some offers but again it's just horrible
I'll do it myself and I'm gonna make way
more money doing it so again doing it
yourself if the deals are not right and
if you don't have a name you're not
gonna have a good deal it's always gonna
be like I'm not giving you money but
it's gonna be 50/50 split
I don't do it myself and we're gonna
have 100 percent split you know so but
first of all is great is great to
showcase your film to put your name out
there and then after that you just you
just hope that that buzz you can use it
for sales when you say do it yourself
what does that entail first of all I use
the company called juice in Canada and
they are the aggregator for iTunes
Amazon and stuff like that there's a
thing in general what they do the
distribution company they're gonna pay
for it but I paid for it so it cost me
like two grand and so that's a big
difference
that's the deal they're gonna give you
mostly it's like I'm gonna give you I'm
gonna pay this to grant for that and but
we're gonna make they were at the
profits I'm like I'll pay and I'm gonna
make all the profit because I know if
the next one my goal is to have a name
so that I can have a good distribution
deal like a big name or does the goal
and because that's make the big
difference now on the horizon for me
right now is my business card kind of
thing like this is what I can do and I
hope the next one is gonna be bigger and
I'm a bigger name I'm still gonna use
the same kind of a team aspect of it but
it doesn't yeah distribution wise if you
don't have a name you're not gonna have
a great deal so do it yourself you know
so this a Grenadier what what are they
doing they're getting the film
ready detective film and they descended
to iTunes they prepare everything and
they send it to iTunes Amazon Hulu
Netflix whatever what there's a lot of
companies like that but the ones you
juice from Canada is pretty cheap and
it's doing a good job pretty well with
the business plan that you put together
I'm sure part of that entailed the
distribution of the film and getting it
out there so what part of that business
plan the distribution leg of it did you
feel you did right and what part would
you go back and change no I think I made
a good I do the business plan my the
businessman myself and I think the deal
that I made with my investor is pretty
you know it's I cannot really tell but
it's it's just me and him that we're
splitting the profit and that's it so
right now that's that's what we're doing
so area all the money that's gonna come
out right now and the own distribution
so anything that's coming in I'm doing
it I'm gonna get the money so then after
that I'm splitting with my investor so
but when you have other distribution
then you have I would have to split with
them my investor with myself but but I
think for this one at least I want to
make sure that my investor get all his
money back before I get paid that's one
a big important thing for trust and you
should I look I'm not getting paid for
this it's all about the film first and
you guys so but you have business plan
wise it was more this is the FEMA want
to do this is the market how everything
is working right now here's some film
that makes some of the money that can be
that you can maybe identify with and
most it was just like profit between me
and him so it was a very simple business
plan again it was I don't think it's the
business than you really sold in yes it
has a beautiful visual and stuff like
that but it's mostly the work before I
decide interviews of me that I wasn't
magazine and stuff like that this was
like okay he's not just a big talker it
did some stuff and I think that's way
more important than any business deal
it's all about sure that you can do and
achieve something where did you learn to
put together this business plan like did
you is there some template or yeah you
get the template and then you just
delete what you don't want in it and
I've changed it with pictures just to
sell the vision this is the location
that I already got that personal I had
the castle the white there's and all
those stuff it's easy to find a wide
Izzard waterfall stuff like got nothing
so
you just you just have to have the guts
to go there and shoot and have the
willingness to just like Akiko I'm gonna
do something so ambitious and just go
anywhere and that's the big part of the
film that I want to do is that you
showcase to people look what you can do
with nothing with 85 grand you can
travel around the world it doesn't cost
anything island you get one camera all
the red dragon stuff was shot and held
you don't need big rigs and everything
just go shoot at fun and make something
different
ambitious and that's gonna make an
impact and because everything's so far
everything people saw the people who saw
the film was just like oh my god it
looks great and he looks so a big-budget
I was like yeah it's three people and
stuff like that so I think it's just a
good business card to show and inspire
people just don't wait go do something
and that I hope that thing can inspire
people to go do something because it's
not impossible to get a castle or white
desert or get motorcycles or cars and
stuff like that it's you just have to
search and be polite and have the drive
and devotion to target and be a little
bit good seller and then then people if
they feel their passion and I think
that's what I'm that's what I have I'm
passionate and I think people feel that
and after that then you hope you're
gonna say yes
you